technology has grown much in the present
and is making a significant impact on
all the carriers all those technologies
came from developing new software and
products that require a lot of coding
and programming coding and programming
are the means that help in the
development of software and products
hey everyone welcome to yet another
exciting video from simply learn in this
session we will be discussing how to
start coding however before we begin
make sure that you have subscribed to
our youtube channel and don't forget to
hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simplylearn
now let's take a look at the agenda for
today's discussion
first we will begin with learning what
exactly is coding then we shall discuss
how to start coding after that we will
walk through some platforms to learn
coding followed by that the trending
programming languages then we will
discuss some top most job opportunities
and their salaries and finally we will
wind up the session by learning some
benefits of coding i hope i made myself
clear with the agenda now without
further ado let's get started with the
first topic of this session
so what is coding
coding is a process of passing
instructions to communicate with the
computer using programming languages it
also helps to pass actions and methods
to the computer and instructs what to do
and how to do it in a detailed manner
moving forward let's understand how to
start coding
there are a number of ways to learn
coding like learning from online blogs
online podcasts communities or group of
coders on social media and other
platforms youtube videos stack overflow
github
self design projects and portfolios
online bootcamps online hackathons and
many more let's have a look over some
top ways to learn coding and we have
online bootcamps
youtube videos
social media real-time projects
events and coding challenges development
tools github and stack overflow now
let's understand each one of them in
detail
in these pandemic situations the
possibility to learn coding through
institutions or other ways is much more
difficult to overcome these situations
online bootcamps have mainly come into
focus
these are helping the students and all
professionals to learn coding quite
easily without any hassle
there are thousands of online bootcamps
available on internet to learn coding
there are many challenges and projects
available on the internet to make it
easy for everyone to learn coding
these bootcamps also provide some
related certifications on the course and
repeat
these online bootcamps also provide some
related certifications on the course you
have studied which is a huge benefit of
learning coding and the next one in the
list is youtube videos
youtube has become the best platform to
learn coding there are many videos
available on youtube about coding
they upload videos with different
content and provide a different aspect
youtube provides and has videos with
different content and helps to get
certified and improve in getting more
command over coding
there are many challenges live classes
and webinars in various languages to
help and make it easy to learn coding
and the next one in the list is social
media
in this modern world the growth of
social media is increasing rapidly
because of the advantages it has
this helps everyone from various
perspectives these social media will
help learn coding by promoting a number
of videos and information about the
latest technologies which can show more
impact in less time
these also help in uploading the videos
and providing the details of the latest
courses and technologies
social media can be easily available in
every kind of situation
and the next one in the list is real
time projects real time projects help in
learning coding skills and improve the
knowledge and concentration towards
coding
projects usually involve a team which
can be a huge benefit in learning coding
if any question or problem arises it can
be easy for discussing with the team
which improves the coding knowledge
another huge benefit in working with
real-time projects is improving
communication skills which helps in
increasing the concentration over coding
and the next one in the list is events
and coding challenges thousands of
events and coding challenges are
available on the internet these are a
huge benefit to learn coding these
provide you with an idea about how the
code should be written according to the
challenges and helps to get more command
over coding
once you are capable of solving the
challenges and events then it is easy
for you to implement code and program
these skills can help you improve in
your debugging and development speed
which can be a massive advantage in
starting to learn coding and the next
one in the list is development tools
development tools involve various tools
with different development which helps
you to work under multiple programming
languages once you get in touch with all
the tools you're working on you can get
a good idea of how to learn and the
requirements you should follow to get
more attention
these tools are much more helpful in
improving your coding skills and get
more command over different coding and
programming languages the next one in
the list is github
github is a web-based internet provider
used for internet hosting for software
development and version control of git
facilitates social coding by providing a
web interface to the git code repository
and management tools for collaboration
github can be thought of a serious
social networking site for software
developers github is so intuitive to use
and its version control tools are so
helpful for collaboration
non-programmers have also begun to use
github to work on document based and
multimedia projects
the final one in the list is the stack
overflow stack overflow is the largest
and most popular and preferred online
community to learn coding
stack overflow is the largest and most
popular and preferred online community
to learn coding it is filled with
questions and answers on a wide range of
topics in computer programming for
professional and enthusiastic
programmers
examples of code and explanation is
provided in a proper way that can help
in growing your knowledge on coding and
help to understand quickly
and these are a few ways to learn coding
and now let's have a look over some of
the top platforms to learn coding
so some of the top platforms to learn
coding are the first one scale up
skill up platform is offered by simply
learn solutions private limited which
was founded by mr krishna kumar
it offers free online courses for those
who are looking for better content
the main goal through scale up is to
build strong foundational skills for
career growth skill up also offers live
webinars with the professionals to help
in the growth of technology next we have
w3 schools w3 schools is a freemium
educational website to learn coding
derived from the world wide web created
in the year 1998. this is one of the top
websites for learning coding mainly for
people looking for some content and grip
over the subject which involves beginner
to advanced and the next platform we
have is hacker rank hackerrank is a
technical company that focuses on the
competitive programming challenges for
both consumers and businesses it helps
in hiring for other companies and helps
in delivering good content it includes
java c plus plus php python sql
javascript and spans multiple computer
science domains
and the next platform on the list is
linkedin learning linkedin learning is
an american website offering video
courses by industry experts and software
creativity and business skills
all these courses on linkedin fall into
three categories business creative and
technology it was founded in the year
1995 by linda wenman as lynda.com
all the courses on linkedin fall into
three categories
business creative and technology it was
founded in the year 1995 by linda wenman
as lynda.com there are 15 000 plus
courses and learning paths offered by
linkedin learning it is a subsidiary of
linkedin
these are a few platforms to learn
coding for free now let's have a look at
some of the new programming languages
the new programming languages are
leading in the present situations and
they are helping a lot in development
and growth of software
now let's have a look at some of the
topmost languages and trends we have
so we have python java javascript go
swift and r
let's have a look at some of them in
brief first we have python python is the
most preferred programming language
because of the syntax of python
programming can be easy to understand
for every programmer and this
programming language is also loaded with
full of libraries that help in
implementing scientific computing
working and deployment in python are
supportive and easy in any kind of
environment
next one in the list is java in the
modern time java is the best language to
choose nearly thousands of applications
software and development tools are built
using the java programming language
this technology is mostly used in
creating websites such as youtube google
amazon and much more
the third one in the list is javascript
javascript is responsible for fast and
secure development
the main advantage and perspective are
to provide more interactivity with the
users and coders it also helps in
expanding innovative technologies which
involve animation gaming and rendering
and the fourth one in the list is go
go language helps in building software
in a simple reliable and efficient way
this language also helps to add more
cache for the processor to improve the
performance of the application
go language is also used for advanced
networking and other multi-core
processing
and the fifth one in the list is swift
swift language is easy to understand and
implement because of the syntax which is
quite simple
swift is less error prone because of the
inline support
swift language improves the development
speed which has a considerable advantage
in reducing the issues related to the
cost the last one in the list is r our
language is very scalable and makes it
easy to build aesthetic web applications
this language is mainly developed by
using statistics and data science
knowledge
r acts as a cross-platform programming
language because of the ability to run
on any operating system and these are a
few languages that are in the huge
demand at present now let's have a look
at the top jobs and the salaries
there are a thousand jobs available in
the world if you have a good command of
coding in this session we bought some of
the top jobs leading from the front with
their salaries the first one is data
scientist next we have machine learning
expert python developer cloud architect
and big data engineer
now let's get a brief about the
specialties skills and salaries
let's have a look at the top job for the
session and we have data scientists a
data scientist is a professional who
gathers and analyzes large sets of data
data scientists also process and help in
involving complex problems
they should have some skills like python
r and java data scientists earn 96
48 dollars per annum in the united
states of america and in india it is
around 42 lakhs 80 000 rupees per annum
that's an average count
now next in the number two we have is
machine learning experts
a machine learning engineer is
responsible for building algorithms to
train models
he is also responsible for performance
solutions for complex problems
they should have skills like python
machine learning and r machine learning
engineers earn an average salary of 85
736 dollars per annum in the united
states of america and around 3 lakhs per
annum in india
and these numbers are just for beginners
next at number 3 we have bison developer
python developers develop web and
software applications and integrate user
facing elements into applications they
also help and instruct the organizations
with logical frameworks
they should have skills like python web
frameworks and analytics python
developers earn an average salary of
ninety thousand one hundred dollars per
annum in the united states of america
and around three lakh ninety thousand
rupees per annum in india
and these salaries are big enough and
the number could vary according to your
experience and expertise
at number four we have cloud architect a
cloud architect is an information
technology expert who works on cloud
application design
they also work with the devops engineers
and develop to build the right
technology they should have skills like
aws google cloud and azure
cloud architects earn around 2 lakh 40
000 dollars per annum in the united
states of america and anything around 19
lakhs per annum in india
and at fifth role we have the big data
engineer big data has been a revolution
in every business sector he is
responsible for storing processing and
analyzing the huge data they design and
develop significant data architecture
they should have skills like hadoop
apache spark and sql
big data engineers earn around one lakh
seven thousand dollars per annum in
united states of america and around 23
lakhs 80 000 rupees
in india
so these are some of the top jobs at
present now let's understand the
benefits of learning coding
coding and programming are playing a
massive role in the present day-to-day
life they are showing the capability to
do anything in the present let's see
some of the benefits of learning coding
programming and coding help in improving
creativity while dealing with the
applications and projects they use much
creativity to develop those and require
a lot of creative knowledge which helps
in situations like problem solving
using these it is easy to find solutions
to complex problems perfectly
most jobs in the present are dependent
on technology coding helps to find jobs
quite easily and impact theory growth
coding skills also help in improving
resilience skills which can be a huge
advantage
and this was all for today's session i
hope now you guys got an idea of how to
start coding and what are the ways to
learn coding if you find the information
helpful to build and improve your
knowledge of coding and programming
please subscribe to our youtube channel
if you have any questions would you
please let us know in the comment
section below
and our experts will be happy to solve
all your queries thank you for watching
and stay tuned for more from simply
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here